we are getting Dumber as a nation and a
world humans are getting dumber and
there is a plethora of reasons but of
course mostly it's because of the things
that we put in our bodies and I'm going
to read a couple of them to you
fluoride in the water supply is
hampering children's neuro development
that's one of them pesticides are now
linked to lower intelligence levels and
decreased cognitive function which could
explain most of my friends and and
process fruit pie processed fruits which
I'm sure are coming processed foods
specifically high fructose corn is it
fructose or fructose I had a debate its
fructose i I've been having a lot of
that so I'm not quite sure for yeah high
fructose corn syrup or fructose has been
reduced linked to a reduced IQ I just
had a coke before we started and I think
that was completely okay so I proved it
right there but are we getting dumber
Fred are we getting Dumber what was the
question no I I think that's BS one of
my favorite quotes is guy think Mark
Twain really made it up but he said the
the three biggest lies are lies big lies
and statistics and as soon as the almond
Board Association all the almond growers
came out and said that almonds have been
proven to decrease cancer risk Gaddafi's
going out in my comments I'm always
suspect as a political consultant we did
a lot of polling a lot of studies and
the ones that didn't quite turn out the
way we wanted we wouldn't necessarily
release and I think that's what we're
seeing here I think this is I don't know
who is the National Resources Defense
Fund I don't know who are behind these
things but a lot of people there's if
you really dig deep you'll see that
there is a selfish interest in these
studies a Republican who doesn't believe
in scientific fact I'm shot Kelly what
do you think I'm kind of torn on this
one because you know I look out I look
out and I look out at the world and I
think yes we're definitely getting
dumber
it's it's getting crazy out there but
then again I think about all of the ways
in which we are overwhelmed these days I
mean I feel overwhelmed by everything
and I feel Dumber but then I think it's
also middle-aged and hormones but I
don't know you know the general curve of
civilization if you think like from the
you know the pyramids to now you know
generally I think we're on the uptick a
little bit maybe not a lot but I think
it's a general uptick I think humans are
you know we have a lot of challenges but
you know hey we went to the moon and
someone invented Twitter I don't know
yeah these feel like smart things to me
Aaron dumber smarter what's up well I
think part of it is that did that page
where the article was on also there was
79 things on the page and it's like did
you like the article tweet about it
Facebook about it did you agree with
that Google+ add your friends and I was
like so I think that is in fact part of
it it there's just so much going on that
you're just like you know I also sort of
agree that if you're you know pounded
Fritos and coke and you're you know 900
pounds and you're 10 you're not gonna
pick up a book you'd be less likely
maybe to take a nap than a raid so I
think that is in fact a factor but I
also in all fairness I think I don't see
us really like in such a horrible
decline the article said that he would
bet like a average citizen from Athens
would be more you know you know smarter
and well I'm like all right well come on
you know if we were running around like
sheets and sandals had nothing else to
do you know we'd be reading more but
there's that we got a lot going on yeah
it was just orgies and reading for those
people wasn't it like gods in the sky on
a mountainside yeah there's a lot of
rolling an Oracle they like go to people
who are psychic and like read like I
mean hello this is change yes I mean
yeah wait a minute a carlin giving a
shot to religion
come on now well you guys have given me
a little hope here I think with this
story I thought all three of you were
gonna say yes we're getting dumber I've
been dealing with dumb people every day
and that there's a there's a little bit
of truth it's like you know all those
people we are the smart people were on
the panel yeah you just moved from New
York so does this la thing is like
actually my vitals are peaking right now
and I do feel
despite the intro to this segment just a
little smarter than then I used to I
don't forget bonobos comm is the
official outfitter of the Reuben report
and her code Reuben report for 20% off
your first purchase